[Music]
it is the best-selling book in history
no volume ever written has been more
loved and quoted and its words sometimes
simple and sometimes mysterious should
always be studied carefully it is the
Bible the Word of God welcome to Bible
answers live providing accurate and
practical answers to all your Bible
questions this broadcast is a previously
recorded episode to receive any of the
Bible resources mentioned in this
broadcast call 885 6 7 4 7
once again that's 800 eight three five
six seven four seven now here's your
host from amazing facts international
pastor Doug Batchelor hello listening
friends would you like to hear an
amazing fact if you've heard that
lightning never strikes twice in the
same place you need to think again above
the mouth of the Catatumbo River in
Venezuela where it empties into Lake
Maracaibo you'll find the world's most
frequent natural fireworks display
lightning storms appear in this area an
average of 260 days per year with storms
lasting 10 hours per day and producing
an average of 28 lightning flashes each
minute not to mention a constant Rolling
Thunder it's believed that the Cata
Tomba lightning is caused by the unusual
geologic and atmospheric conditions in
the area almost every afternoon moist
winds blowing across Maracaibo Lake
collide with a cold air from the high
Andes nearby that surround the swampy
Plains this causes tremendous vertical
clouds that produce almost non-stop
thunder and lightning storms because the
lightning storms hover in almost the
same place sailors have referred to it
as the beacon of Maracaibo or the
everlasting storm Guinness Book of World
Records has named this is the place
where the highest annual concentration
of lightning in the world did you know
the Bible talks about a man that climbed
up into a thunder and lightning storm
that hovered above a mountain to stay
with his friends were going to learn
more on this edition of bible answers
[Music]
you're listening to Bible answers live
accurate and practical answers to your
Bible questions
welcome listening friends if you have a
question give us a call we have some
lines open right now the beginning of
the program great time to call in with
your Bible question and that's why we're
here to do our best to answer your
questions about living the Christian
life and the Word of God and here's the
phone number if you want to call in
eight hundred four six three seven two
ninety seven that actually is an acronym
for 800 God says as eight hundred four
six three seven two nine seven we're
also streaming on the internet you can
be watching this right now see what's
happening in the studio at the amazing
facts Facebook page and it'll also be
streaming on the Doug Batchelor Facebook
page and you could watch you can listen
you can tell your friends to join us and
we're gonna study the word together my
name is Doug Batchelor my name is John
Ross good evening friends and let's
start the program with prayer dear
father we thank you that we have this
time once again to be able to open up
your word and study together and father
we ask for your Holy Spirit to be with
each of us we were those who are
listening wherever they might be and
guide us Lord as we open up the word and
maybe we have some clarity to maybe
those questions we have about the Bible
we've never fully understood and we
thank you Lord that we're able to study
together in Jesus name Amen amen now
pastor day you started by talking about
lightning storms and I'm sure if you've
had some experiences as I have spending
some time in the tropics you can have
some rather amazing thunderstorms or
even in the Midwest and some of the most
powerful storms I lived for a while in
what's called Tornado Alley there in
Missouri and the lightning and the
Thunder that would come along and it was
just breathtaking it was something that
I look forward to I mean not everyone
likes it but it's kind of exciting to
have this massive thunderstorm and
lightning and now here is a place that
you spoke about where you almost
guaranteed to have a thunderstorm just
about every day of the year if you show
up the right time you'll get to see some
spectacular
matter of fact when you were reading
that I thought myself man that sure
would be a nice place to visit well I
thought so too in fact if you go online
you can actually see they take tours
there now right now the economy in
Venezuela and the country is sort of in
turmoil but they're still taking people
on tours where they can go to the edge
of the lake and they can see almost
every afternoon except in times of
drought there's gonna be a lightning
show above this one spot and it hovers
there it's really bizarre just violent
flashing rumbling lightning going up in
the sky going down going out and and
it's just like a really divine fireworks
display and it makes me think of a story
in the Bible where it tells us in the
book of Exodus just before the Lord
delivered the Ten Commandments to the
nation of Israel you can look at it and
say next is 19 in Exodus 20 the mountain
was full of thunder and lightning Exodus
20 verse 18 now all the people witnessed
the thunderings and the lightning
flashes and the sound of the trumpet
course is sustained in one place above
the mountain and the mountains smoking
and when the people sought they trembled
and stood afar off and they said to
Moses you speak with us and we'll listen
but don't let God speak with us lest we
die and then you can also read in Exodus
24 13
so Moses arose with his assistant Joshua
and Moses went up into the mountain of
God and the sight of the glory of the
Lord was like a consuming fire on the
top of the mountain in the eyes of the
children of Israel so Moses went into
the midst of the cloud and went up into
the mountain he just climbs up into this
storm of God's presence and this is one
reason I think you find in Revelation
when it talks about like the throne of
God the presence of God says in
Revelation 4 verse 5 and from the throne
proceeded lightnings thunderings and
voice now in our world in the natural
elements the brightest light is
lightning and the loudest noise is
thundering unless you get the explosion
of a volcano or something I suppose and
even some volcanoes produce lightning
and thunder and this glory this
powerful manifestation was displayed by
God when he gave his law when he spoke
to the nation because he was trying to
emphasize and punctuate the the
solemnity and the awesomeness of these
words he was going to speak audibly
before nation and many Christians have
forgotten that the Ten Commandments are
just that they are Commandments they are
not God's Ten recommendations they are
not God's 10 suggestions or 10 good
ideas these are the commandments of God
how many of you listening to think you
could name them do you know them in
order could you recite them used to be
every every kid in a synagogue or a
Sunday School could recite the Ten
Commandments and my father who wasn't
even religious his Baptist Church he had
memorized the Ten Commandments and we've
got a great study folks want to know
where do the Ten Commandments fit into a
Christians experience today doesn't the
Bible say we are not under the law but
under grace what does that mean we have
a free offer that I think you're really
gonna appreciate the study guide that is
our free gift this evening is called
written in stone and it's describing
that event took place on Mount Sinai you
find it recording Exodus chapter 20 and
we'll be happy to send anyone this free
study guide is called written in stone
and the number to call is eight hundred
eight three five six seven four seven
that is the resource phone line again
it's 800 eight three five six seven four
seven and we want to encourage you to
ask for the study guide called written
in stone it will be a blessing as you
study the various verses that you find
in the study guide we ready to go to the
phone lines our first caller this
evening is calling from New York we've
got Anthony Anthony welcome to the
program hello good evening pastors how
are you doing well thank you for calling
great so I want to be married for a few
years and but I do like to try to help
mentor give advice to some of my younger
friends who you know are not yet married
or a pursuing marriage and thinking
about marriage but you know I want to
make sure that I'm gay
good advice and telling them the right
thing and so my question has to do with
combination of texts Genesis chapter 24
verse 4 where it reads about Abraham
telling us I think of Eliezer I said but
you shall go to my country and to my
family and take a wife for my son Isaac
and then we have the fifth commandment
where it says honor thy father and thy
mother write that your days may be long
so obviously you know Isaac had a trust
relationship with his father to allow
him to choose a wife for him but I want
to know what does that mean for us today
do we have to allow our parents to
choose a spouse for us in order to honor
them and if we don't choose the person
that or we choose somebody that day you
know that they didn't choose for us you
know marriage and when they didn't
choose for us is that dishonouring them
and well what does that mean that's a
great question
yeah I'm sorry I didn't mean to step on
your words here bill problem that's a
great question
now it does it does matter first of all
if you are a believer and if your
parents were believers in my case when I
got married I was believing my parents
were not and so you know I couldn't
entirely trust their counsel keep in
mind also in the Bible when there was a
marriage that took place there was often
a contract and obligations of one parent
would be paying a dowry to another so
the parents were involved because they
were often helping to pay the dowry and
sometimes they'd help them get
established it's of course a little
different culture today than we had back
then I believe a lot of marriages would
have a better success rate if young
people who are Christians would listen
to the counsel of their parents now if
you're dating somebody and you've got
Christian parents and your parents and
your grandparents see a lot of red flags
you ought to put a lot of stock in their
wisdom and their judgment and you know
today everyone by watch all these love
stories and they kind of blow off the
idea that you know
the wisdom and counsel of your parents
should be taken as a factor
it's just following your heart kind of
nonsense that people here but I do think
it'd be a good idea if you've got you
know believing parents and they've got a
record of pretty good judgment listen to
their judgment sometimes they won't say
do marry or don't marry they might say
wait a little while and and you don't
give them some advice to you know make
sure you get establish or whatever but
yeah there's I don't believe there's a
Bible command that you should not get
married without your the support of your
mother and father but if they're
believers and you are probably a good
idea to listen to their counsel you know
we do have a book actually it's a study
guide part of our study guide series and
it's just a great resource for Christian
young people that are thinking about
marriage
it's called keys for a happy marriage
it's got some very practical advice and
it's past that I've mentioned if you're
a Christian your parents are Christian
then it's it's very important to heed
the counsel of your parents and you know
prayerfully consider what they are
saying sometimes parents are able to see
things they know you well and they're
able to see certain personality traits
and they'll be able to guide a person as
to what character traits will will fit
well or if there's areas of concern and
and so it just makes a lot of sense to
listen to the counsel of god-fearing
parents yeah no I agree but having said
that something just popped into my mind
I thought I should mention and I've run
into situations before where there is
for example a mother maybe the parents
were divorced and there's a mother and
she's got an adult son and he's thinking
of marrying and the mother is so
concerned that the wife is gonna replace
her that nobody's good enough for her
son and you know I see these guys
they're they're 55 years old the mother
would never approve of it the marrying
button and so there's a balance between
respecting and factoring in their advice
and yet Bible says a man leaves his
father and mother and cleave unto his
wife and so there is I think God builds
in a certain desire for independence and
everybody at some point but that should
be factored so of course the free offer
will send it to anyone who calls and ask
the number the number to call for that
is 800 835
five six seven four seven and I asked
for the study guide called keys for a
happy marriage thank you for your call
Anthony we've got Joshua listening in
Texas Josh you're welcome to the program
hey Baptists are you done great thanks
for calling your question my question
was I was reading today Hebrews chapter
six verses four through six and that
text is regarding salvation and I was
looking to different pastors and I got
different answers in regards to Hebrews
chapter six
some say it's one saved always saved and
that doesn't seem right
because if you do that then some people
if they're tempted can see salvation as
an excuse to do anything that they want
to do but then I look at a pastor who
also says that well you could lose your
salvation but I tell you what Joshua
before you say any more about it we've
got a lot of friends listening that
don't know what text we're talking about
can I read it to them yeah yeah so
friends this is hebrews chapter six
verse and i'll read verse four to six
for it is impossible for those who were
once enlightened and they've tasted the
heavenly gift and have become partakers
of the Holy Spirit and have tasted the
good word of God and the powers of the
age to come if they fall away to renew
them again to repentance since they
crucify again for themselves the Son of
God and put him to an open shame which
of course sounds like you know after a
person is fully converted if they fall
away it's impossible to renew them to
repentance so now go ahead and finish
your thought there Joshua I just wanted
folks to have the context yeah so my
thought was in regards to if you lose
your salvation and I can think of a
biblical examples like Saul and but how
can the Christian be assured that they
won't lose their salvation kind of I
don't want to fall in one ditch or fall
into the other ditch so what's uh
properly in interpreting this scripture
yeah I think we were dealing with that
question this week also someone asked
but there is a delicate balance
in every Christians life between having
assurance of salvation God doesn't want
us to walk around wringing our hands
wondering all the time am I gonna make
it am I gonna make it
and at the same time living a life of
caution where you know Paul said let
everyone examine himself whether he be
in the faith though there there needs to
be some self-examination so that we're
not self deceived Paul said lest I
preach to others and I myself am a
castaway Paul said there was a risk he
could be preaching to others and be lost
because he was presuming on God's grace
so there's a balance in a Christian life
Jesus says that if we come to him he
will in no wise let us go
no man can snatch us out of his father's
hand if we're daily surrendering to
Christ and taking up our cross and
following him
we have no concern about will I make it
the Lord says he's the author and
finisher of our faith we need to just
stay close to Jesus be growing in
sanctification following him
consistently but at the same time it's a
reckless for someone to say well I
accepted Jesus when I was 12 years old
at church I said this prayer I'm saved
now and then you don't go to church and
you live for the world and you talk like
the world and say well but I'm saying
that of course is presumption and you
know Jesus said you'll know them by
their works by their fruits
so does that make sense yeah I was
thinking about when it comes to all
situation he himself got the Holy Spirit
but then it left him because of all the
crimes that he did right and then if we
look at David he also gets the spirit
but he also committed wrong things like
killing of Uriah
Uriah sleeping with Bathsheba but the
Holy Spirit didn't leave him sort of
like what is the difference there with
David and Saul you know that's a good
point
even Samson after he began to misbehave
he was filled with the Holy Spirit says
the Spirit of the Lord came upon him and
even after he was spirit filled he
misused that spirit and that power God
gave him a few times for selfish
purposes and God did not
draw his spirit until you know he he
kind of went to the point where he was
about to sell a soul to Delilah
but even Samson when he prayed in the
end the Holy Spirit was given to him
again and I trust he was forgiven so you
can definitely grieve away God's Spirit
permanently and I think some like Samson
grieve it away at least temporarily
until they repent you know we do have a
book that you might find interesting
that Joshua it's called can a saved man
choose to be lost and listed before
anyone wanting to learn more about what
does the Bible say about how one is to
lose their salvation I will be happy to
send this to anyone who calls and asked
the number again he's eight hundred
eight three five six seven four seven
and you can ask for it's one of our
actual books it's called can a saved man
choose to be lost will be happy to send
this to anyone who calls and asks next
caller that we have is John listening in
California John welcome to the program
Jimmy pastors evening yes my question is
do you is there female angels does it
say anywhere in the Bible let's talk
about that for a second
one of the obvious differences between
men and women is their anatomy in that a
woman's body is clearly designed for not
only childbirth but to nurse children
and that were job you know be one of the
ways you distinguish a difference
between a man and a woman
but what if angels do not marry nor are
given in marriage then angels male or
female probably don't have the same kind
of plumbing and so I don't think there's
any example in the Bible of female
angels you do have there's one vision
where there's two women with wings like
a stork but I don't think they're angels
at Zechariah sees and but you know
usually in the Bible when an angel
appears it refers to them as a man or he
so I don't know of any verse in the
Bible where it says an angel and uses
the term she
she's still there okay yes so if angels
don't marry and procreate and I don't
know why God would make angels really
any particular gender but they're
typically referred to in the hee
alright well thank you for your call
John and next one of the babies calling
from Florida we have a liar who is
listening liar welcome to the program hi
so my question has to do with women's
role in ministry and in the Bible I
particularly have a question about a
verse are you sure um it's things like
first great news and it says 34 women
should remain silent in the churches
they are not allowed to speak but must
be in submission so you're in first
Corinthians what chapter thirty fourteen
okay there we go
first Corinthians 14 verse 34 yes sorry
so we should remain silent in the
churches they are not allowed to speak
but must be in submission as law says
but they not to inquire about something
they should ask their own husbands at
home or it is a disgrace for a woman to
speak in the church yeah you're
wondering does this mean a woman can
never speak in a church whenever you see
a verse like this that says something
and you go wow look at other verses and
find out where the preponderance of
evidence is now is this verse saying
that a woman is not allowed to open her
mouth and make any kind of verbal
communication in a holy place I don't
think so because they're places where it
has women praying in church you've got
the story where Joseph and Mary bring
baby Jesus to the temple in the Gospel
of Luke in Anna who is a prophetess is
there and ostensibly she speaks didn't
otherwise why would they bring her into
the story and you know you've got the
the daughters of Philip that did
prophesy so I don't think this is saying
that a woman could never speak in the
church but
the bible does say there's a distinction
in the roles in the law between men and
women and the problem current the
Corinthian church evidently had some
outstanding problems because he had men
and women going to the church the men
did not sit with a women if you travel
through Indian another Middle East
you'll see many of the churches the
women men don't sit together they figure
want to make sure and keep your eyes on
the Lord and they get different places
the Jews had the courtyard for the women
and they could pray but I think the
services were becoming disruptive with
women calling across to their husbands
and teaching them publicly what Paul was
saying Paul said that's kind of
humiliating them well you know you also
have the verse
st. chapter in verse 40 in it I think
this summarizes what Paul's council is
to the church it says let all things be
done decently and in order and if you
read on he's addressing certain issues
that were prevalent in the church in
Corinth and it appears that their church
services could get a little out of hand
with people saying things or calling out
or disrupting the service and so in that
context Paul is actually addressing a
specific situation in a specific church
it's not necessarily applying to all
churches because we do have are the
examples in the Bible for example Hannah
where she went to the temple and she was
praying so it's it's not meaning that a
woman can never speak in a church
setting yeah there Aliyah yes that
clears it up all right hey you know we
do have a book we'll send you that
addresses this verse I wrote this so
about 810 years ago it's called the role
of women in ministry and of course God
calls men and women into various roles
of ministry he wants every believer to
be using their gifts and so it answers
some of these questions we'll send you a
free copy the number to call for that
he's eight hundred eight three five six
seven four seven and you can ask for the
book called the woman's role in ministry
and we'll be happy to send that to
anyone who calls and asks we've got Glen
listening from Ohio Glen welcome to the
program say good evening to you out
there but it's a good night hearing that
though thanks for taking the call
sure my question is seemingly has to do
with an episode that happened in the
book of marks we have Jesus talking to
some folks there and they're telling him
Lord we cast out demons and healed the
sick and the dumb speak and the Deaf
hear and Jesus reported back to them
depart from me he will who work iniquity
I never knew you and the interesting
thing to me is who was the you that
Jesus was talking to what was the
iniquity that he accused him of what did
he mean when he said I never knew you
and perhaps the most intriguing question
of all is he did be healing all right
let's first look in I'm gonna read in
Matthew chapter 7 verse 21 this is
almost a parallel verse Jesus said not
everyone who says to me Lord Lord will
enter into the kingdom of heaven but he
that does the will of my father in
heaven many will say to me in that day
Lord Lord have we not prophesied in your
name cast out devils in your name and
done many wonderful works in your name
and then I'll profess to them I never
knew you depart from me you who work
lawlessness and the word lawlessness
there is iniquity it's the same word
first of all the iniquity iniquity means
lawlessness or to live in an open
high-handed ly disobedient way once you
know God's will sin means that you
simple you don't have the ability to hit
the mark lawlessness means or iniquity
that you deliberately aim in a different
direction you're not even trying to hit
the mark so this is Jesus is talking to
people who say look we went to church
you know we we did all these outwardly
religious things and in your name and
he'll say I never knew you you really
were doing your own thing because you
did not do the will of my father Christ
said in another place not everyone who
says unto me Lord Lord will enter the
kingdom but they that do the will of my
father which is in heaven
and that's also in Luke 6:46 so the the
ones that Christ is addressing here are
hypocrites
and keep in mind he's talking here in
Matthew he said some of you pray to be
seen of men you give to be seen of men
you fast now these are religious things
they're praying they're giving they're
fasting but they're doing it for human
reward he said I don't know you your you
know depart from me you who work
iniquity a lot of the religious leaders
in Jesus day were very religious very
zealous very fastidious about their
religion but they rejected Jesus and
crucified him and he said you don't know
me and so a saving relationship is to
know Christ and that's from John chapter
17 it says this is eternal life that
they might know thee the only true God
and Jesus Christ whom you have sent so
we don't want the Lord to say I don't
know you if we know the Lord we're gonna
be listening to his voice he said my
sheep hear my voice and they follow me
we'll be obeying him and being willing
to do his will from day to day so I hope
that's a great question Glenn I hope
that helps a little bit and your passage
is in both mark and in Matthew 8 3 read
at you from Matthew your friends we're
just gonna take a break in a few moments
for a few moments get a drink of water
coming back we see you lined up for
questions
Kaleo Kalyan Oh Rick Karl we'll be right
there
stay tuned Bible answers live will
return shortly
if you enjoy hearing solid biblical
answers on Bible answers live you can
have those same insights at your
fingertips through the amazing facts
prophecy Study Bible
the updated hardcover version is
available at its lowest price ever and
include the complete set of amazing
facts 27 study guides plus a Bible
numbers and symbols charts and eight
pages of colorful maps this best-ever
Bible gives you a biblical cyclope dick
index words of Christ in red chronology
of the Old Testament
along with Doug Bachelors how to study
the Bible feature and much more call us
at AF bookstore to learn more about it
at one eight hundred five thirty eight
seventy to seventy five the amazing
facts prophecy Study Bible stands apart
from other Bibles giving you the same
solid answers you hear each week on
Bible answers live order your copy today
at AF bookstore calm or by calling 1-800
five three eight seventy two seventy
five
what if you could know the future what
would you do
[Music]
what would you change to see the future
you must understand the past Alexander
the Great becomes king when he's only 18
but he's a military prodigy a hundred
and fifty years in advance Cyrus had
been named wrong was violent they were
ruthless they were determined the Gospel
writers see his death as a fulfillment
of salvation this intriguing documentary
hosted by Pastor Doug Batchelor explores
the most striking bible prophecies that
have been dramatically fulfilled
throughout history kingdoms in time get
your copy today available now on DVD
blu-ray or USB for more information
visit kingdoms in time.com you're
listening to Bible answers live where
every question answered provides a
clearer picture of God and his plan to
save you so what are you waiting for get
practical answers about the good book
for a better life today
if you have a question about the Bible
or living the Christian life call us now
at 800-831-6273 program calling with
your Bible questions we will do our best
in the next half an hour to answer them
I'm Doug Batchelor my name is John Ross
we got our next caller listening from
Miami
Claudia welcome to the program hi
Colleen because I have a question about
Elijah and the other prophet who was
following him and all the miracles that
he was doing because he had the Spirit
of God with him yes and through that he
had a double portion so relating to
David I think he he well my question is
about why when the person who was
following him I don't know his name
Elijah you had a right jaw and then the
Elijah got the double portion of
Elijah's spirit okay the second one
Elijah Elijah Elijah yes and then him he
was going up and then he saw own kids no
like I don't know what age like 13 years
some young people came out and they were
making fun of him because they were they
were calling them okay in English you
would say go up you bald head is they
were okay yeah and you're wondering why
did then he curse them and the Bears
came out and tore them so you're
wondering why did that happen
yeah so that you find the story of
Elijah and Elijah in
second Kings chapter 2 and not long
after Elijah gets a double portion of
Elijah's spirit very early in his
ministry people had heard that God took
Elijah to heaven and a fiery chariot
Elijah who stayed behind got a double
portion of Elijah's spirit and then some
young people came out of the city and
they were mocking him because evidently
he was bald and they said go up you bald
head in other words why don't you go up
like he lied you went up they didn't
really believe he lied you went to
heaven and they were teasing them and
taunting him as he walked down the road
go up you bald head now this is the
prophet of God he is the prophet chosen
by God filled with the Spirit of God for
the nation if he didn't do something
right here at the outset of his ministry
to help them recognize that they needed
to Revere his position so he turned
around and he pronounced a curse on them
and it says two she bears came out of
the woods and mauled 42 of them now it
doesn't say any of them were killed it
makes it sound like the Bears went
rampaging through them she bears her
mother bears are very vicious kind of
went rampaging through them biting and
scratching and those young people had
scars to remind them never to curse the
prophet of God again for the remainder
of Elijah's ministry
nobody wagged his tongue at him and he
continued to minister probably fifty
years so that's a good question Claudio
hopefully that helps they were making
fun of him saying go up bald hit in
other words go up like Elijah if you're
really a prophet of God and he would not
allow their continued mocking thanks for
that we have is Rick's listening in
California Rick welcome to Bible answers
live hi pastors how are you today doing
great thank you for calling your
question oh my well my question is a
little bit about the mark of the beast
and some modern things that are going on
around the Kovach virus there's a patent
on some technology that's going to be in
I guess a tattoo that is going to mark
the people that have had the vaccination
and the patent number is wo this is what
the UN wo
20 2006 zero six zero six and one of the
interesting things about it is the
luminescent or reflective chemical or
whatever that's going to be in this
invisible tattoos it's only visible with
a certain kind of light I guess yeah
infrared light
oh yeah it's called luciferase or
something I'm not sure if I'm
pronouncing it correctly
yeah well lose sight loose okay is a
it's a Greek word for light so that
wanted surprise right right so you
wonder it exists the mark of the beast
well I don't think it is a gentleman
that I know that was showing me this
information told me when you go get the
vaccination they're gonna mark you and
then that that's it you're sealed and
you're done you're you know you're never
going to go to heaven you're you've sold
your soul to the devil and I know you've
talked about the mark being more about
in the right hand what we do with our
actions and in our mind how we're
thinking yeah so I think he's off base
but I still kind of wanted your thoughts
because I see a lot of what's going on
and just the evil that's pervading as
you know coming you know Satan's a nice
hand in it yeah well I think that there
there is cause for concern when for when
people lose their freedoms and if you
know government powers start telling you
you can't go to church right away you've
got cause for concern and I do
understand that if there is a viable
pandemic and and you're gathering
together can help spread this contagion
that you know you can risk people's
lives and I think that as Christians you
don't want to tempt the Lord you don't
want to endanger someone else's life but
the very fact that governments have had
to take this step and then you know they
haven't mandated it yet they're
recommending I think what I've heard so
far is that they're saying that the
vaccine if they develop one that the
vaccine is going to be you know
voluntary and they're gonna encourage
people who are high-risk to take it
because they say at the beginning
they're not even gonna have enough for
buddy and that you know there's wanting
to know how do we know that you've been
vaccinated well I'm not sure they're
gonna develop a new sophisticated system
they've been giving vaccines to people
for I just was reading about they had
vaccine had been franklin's day for
smallpox and people were keeping records
we keep records of our children's
vaccinations right now so the idea that
now they need a computer chip for this
particular flu vaccine all it is a
coronal virus is a flu vaccination they
have them every year so it's troubling
if they say but for this particular
vaccination you need to get a tattoo
that can be seen with an ultraviolet
light or they're gonna put an RF D under
your skin or something like that I'm
hearing all kinds of things and I'm just
kind of sitting back and waiting to see
what the truth is but we've got to be
careful not to speculate ourselves into
hysteria about what this is biblically
the mark of the beast is not a vaccine
it is not a tattoo either worshiping the
Beast is gonna mean something you do
with your life in your heart and your
actions God is not gonna punish people
because they get a vaccine so we do have
a lesson on this baby yeah I read it
before yeah it is cold the mark of the
beast I'm gonna be happy to send this
lesson out to anyone who asked for it
the number he's 883 five six seven four
seven yeah so the study guide called the
mark of the beast and you'll learn
everything that the Bible has to say
about this very important subject
especially related to the last days in
that's eight hundred eight three five
six seven four seven thank you Rick we
got car listening in Canada crawl
welcome to the program good evening
gentlemen thank you for taking my call
yes my question get real close to your
phone Karl because that your fainting
awful that sorry sorry what will happen
after the Second Coming so essentially
they pointed me to Isaiah 66 verses 19
where it says I
establish a sleighing among them I will
send survivors from among them to
Tarshish put unloaded the the archer the
two ball to je je van and to the island
far away and to the nation who have not
heard of my fame or see my glory so they
would proclaim my glory among the
nations in other words what they're
saying to me is that Jesus will come he
will establish his kingdom on the earth
and he will send ambassadors to these
places that never heard about him so
that they get a chance to learn about
Jesus
you know I the prophesy there in Isaiah
I do think it's a prophecy but I don't
think it's after the Lord comes I think
in Isaiah's prophecy he continues like
you see in Revelation and Daniel he goes
back and forth he's not doing it all in
chronological order when he talks about
in chapter 66 verse 19 I think he's
saying that when He pours out the Spirit
on his people that he's going to send
them Tarshish was a very it was a
furthest Kingdom that's where Jonah
wanted to flee he's naming kingdoms that
are far off that he might send
messengers to them and they will hear to
be ready so they don't experience what
happens in when it says for with fire
and with his sword the Lord will plead
with all flesh and it talks about God's
coming again behold the Lord will come
verse 15 with fire and his periods he's
saying before he comes he wants as many
as possible to be saved he'll send
representatives to these far-off lands
to here I don't think after he comes and
and the judges people with fire in the
sword then he's going to send out
missionaries to convert people so I
don't know what your thoughts but you
know there's a parallel verse that we
find in Revelation chapter 18 that talks
about an angel coming down from heaven
it says the earth is illuminated with
these glory and really this is a
description of what we call the loud cry
it's a special evangelistic effort with
the Holy Spirit where the gospel is
preached around the world especially to
those who have never heard it before and
that kind of parallels the experience
that we find here in verse 19 of Isaiah
66 where the gospel is going out to the
far reaches the
of course Revelation chapter 18 is just
prior to the second coming of Christ and
so one would assume that what we're
reading about here in verse 19 is
referring to just before Jesus comes or
before probation closes a special
proclamation of the gospel and then of
course after Jesus comes who know from
other passages in the scripture that the
righteous are taking to heaven and the
wicked or destroyed that the brightness
of his coming Jesus says he that's holy
let him be holy still he that's filthy
let him be filthy still behold I come
quickly and my reward is with me so
after Jesus comes there's only two
groups those are righteous and saved and
those who are wicked and lost there's no
changing sides yeah it's something else
that I think you're seeing in this verse
Carl is you look in the last part in
verse like 20 and 21 it says that out of
all nations he's gonna call people to
come to him and I will make of them
priests and Levites this is something
that also happened when the gospel went
out after Pentecost it'll happen again
before the second coming the the Jews
were shocked that Paul was preaching and
Peter to the Gentiles and then the
Gentiles were filled with the spirit and
they went out preaching and so I think
Isaiah's letting us know the gospel is
not just for the Jews it was for
everybody in this prophecy thank you for
your call a good question Mexico love
the babies Chris and he's listening from
Nebraska Chris welcome to the program
hello good evening evening I hope you
guys they're full tonight we're doing
great and thank you for calling your
question Chris my question is referring
to the different types of meat in 1st
Timothy 4 verse 4 King chapter 4 verse 4
and my question was does God really say
all animals are clean if preyed upon
all right let's read that your thoughts
yeah let's start with verse 1 in 1st
Timothy 4 so we get the context now the
spirit speaks expressly that in the
latter times some will depart from the
faith giving heed to deceiving spirits
and doctrines of devils speaking lies in
hypocrisy having their own conscience
seared with a hot iron forbidding to
marry and commanding to
abstain from foods that God created to
be received with Thanksgiving all right
now first of all it says this offshoot
or this deviant religion which forbid
people to marry is there a large church
somewhere that prefer bids its
priesthood to marry and commands to
abstain from foods God has created they
say that you can't eat fish in certain
days of the week and is he saying when
he says in verse 4 for every creature of
God is good and nothing to be refused is
Paul saying that everything that crawls
is meant to be eaten if you pray over it
now I gotta think about that for a
second first of all that would mean you
know Christians can eat cockroaches and
bats look at all the trouble the world's
in now because people are eating bats
and pangolins does that mean that you
can eat skunks and buzzards and
technically humans are creatures every
creature of God is good nothing to be
refused does that mean goddess in
cannibalism okay no he's not talking
about this if you look in Paul's
writings he talks about some of the
Orthodox Christians and Jews that were
afraid to eat meat speaking of clean
meats you know goat sheep so forth that
was being sold in the public markets
because before the Romans and the Greeks
butchered something they offered it to
Greek and Roman deities they said oh we
can't eat it and Paul was saying look
the legalists among the the people are
saying you can't eat anything that had
been offered to an idol Paul said look
if you didn't offer to an idol
don't worry pray over it God will bless
it he wasn't saying that Christians can
eat anything to call across their plate
because there is no Christian parent
listening to me right now that would
tell their children they can eat
anything they want if they pray over it
by that reasoning a kid on his way to
school in the morning can make a banana
split and smothered in chocolate syrup
and when his parents say what in the
world do you think you're doing they'll
say but don't worry mom dad I'm gonna
pray over it and God is gonna bless it
Bible says God is not mocked whatever
you sow you're going to reap and if
you're eating foods that are full of
cholesterol or they're unclean you're
gonna
the disease you're gonna get the
cholesterol god we cannot mock God or
tempt the Lord this is talking about a
cult large church that would arise that
drifted from the Bible and it's also
talking about those who were criticizing
others for eating things sold in the
Roman marketplace clean foods we're
talking about you know the last verse
they verse five says for it is
sanctified by the Word of God so it's
not just about any kind of food but a
food that is set apart or sanctified by
the Word of God and of course we know
that the Bible does distinguish the
clean from the unclean foods yeah so
that's something to take into
consideration thanks for your call Chris
we've got Jennifer listening in
California Jennifer welcome to the
program hi so my question is is it okay
for a married Christian couple that's a
fair question
and we get that periodically you know
Bible talks about keeping the Sabbath
holy and some folks will say well the
Bible says you know not doing your ways
or seeking your own pleasure now when
God says and I think that's Isaiah 58 or
he says not finding your own going your
own ways or seeking your own pleasure
does that mean that you're only supposed
to do that which is unpleasant on the
Sabbath did God give us taste buds so we
can enjoy food absolutely and there
there's nothing wrong with enjoying the
things that God has blessed and
sanctified on the Sabbath and I would
think that if the first thing God tells
Adam and Eve he makes him on the sixth
day of the week and then God tells them
before the Sun Goes Down he's now just
presented Eve to Adam he says be
fruitful and multiply but don't touch
her for the next twenty-four hours our
vice versa I I don't think that there's
anything in the scripture that says that
that is a Sabbath command now if a
husband and wife agree together Paul
says that if they're fasting and if they
greeted to abstain now there's nothing
wrong with eating food on the Sabbath
but if you're a fasting woman you're
fast and you don't eat food you can also
be fasting from physical intimacy and
Paul said the husband and wife ought to
agree say let's spend this
I'm fasting and will deny ourselves
physical food and some of the other
physical pleasures that would be
perfectly appropriate in a marriage he
said but do not prolong that lest you be
tempted and become inconsistent I'm
paraphrasing so sure a couple can agree
to fast and pray and to separate even
through the Sabbath but otherwise I
don't see a command that says that it
would be wrong so I hope that helps a
little bit that's a good question
all right thank you here Thank You
Jennifer we do have a book that talks
about marriage and it's for anyone we
mentioned once before it's called keys
to happy marriage and we'll send that
out to anyone who asks for it
the number is 883 five six seven four
seven ask for the study guide called
keys for a happy marriage no pet
passwords just jumping in sorry I forgot
I think we both forgot we have a book
called how to keep the Sabbath holy
that's right and I think it's an source
- yeah it's the same size you could
either one Jennifer so again the number
one more time eight hundred eight three
five six seven four seven ask the book
how to keep the Sabbath holy
we've got Bradley listening in Missouri
Bradley welcome to the program hello
pastors good evening thank you for
taking my question yeah so my question
actually comes from I think it's kind of
a similar question that was asked few
minutes ago but in first before when it
talks about giving heed to seducing
spirits and doctrines of devils all
talks about forbidding to marry and
commanding saying for me which God has
created to be received with Thanksgiving
my understanding that you know there are
meats that are created to be received
with Thanksgiving the Queen meat right
so my question here is Paul talking
about vegetarianism as the doctrine of
devils when he says that there are those
that will command to abstain from
cleaning no I I think that you know Paul
is making a prophecy he says the spirit
speaks expressly that in the latter
times
some will depart from the faith I think
Paul is talking about this Antichrist
power that was gonna rise and he talks
about as its second Thessalonians that
then that wicked one who opposes all
that is called God will sit in the
temple of God showing him selphie has
God Paul I think is foretelling the very
same power that they would forbid
marriage which is perfectly holy normal
yeah the verse talking about their past
that is 2nd Thessalonians chapter 2
verse 3 and 4 yeah you can read it yes
it says let no one deceive you by any
means for that day will not come unless
they be a falling away first that the
man of sin be revealed the son of
perdition who opposes and exalts himself
above all that is called God or that is
worshipped so that he sits as God in the
temple of God showing himself that He is
God
yeah and so this is I think paralleled
when Paul says some will depart from the
faith Thessalonians says fall away and I
don't think it has anything to do is
vegetarianism being a doctrine of devils
why would God say you have to be meat
eat meat to be healthy if he made Adam
and Eve vegetarians and in heaven will
be vegetarian so there's nothing sinful
about being a vegetarian doctors today
are recommending it and as a lot of
evidence that it will prolong a person's
life and it's it's better for their
health so not to mention it's a lot
better for the animals if you don't eat
them but so no I don't think it's a
doctrine of devils to be a vegetarian is
where you is that kind of what you were
wondering Brady absolutely thank you for
the clarification and thank you thanks
so much keep us in your prayers
all right who's that Theresa next yes
Theresa listening in British Columbia
Theresa welcome to the program thank you
very much Pastor John and pastor Doug um
thank you for sharing your knowledge so
Jennifer Lee for all of us
can you explain how Jesus or anyone will
pray for long periods of time for
example all night
like that literal or how do they like do
they take breaks do they do they repeat
things I mean some of us don't have the
gift of words so I'm just wondering how
that happened
I used to wonder that too and you know I
think the more that you spend time
talking to the Lord in prayer and the
more you sense his voice speaking back
to you in prayer your conversations can
get deeper and longer and you really do
you know begin to see that you've got a
prolonged communication happening only a
couple times in my life to be honest if
I spent the entire night in prayer but I
was with somebody else
and we were studying we would study and
we'd pray about what we studied then
we'd studied and we pray about what we
studied and then all of a sudden we
notice his Sun is coming up and I was
just so excited at one time I think
spent the night in parishes awake
driving all night but yeah Jesus you
know he he had a relationship with the
father where he's from one on one I
think also just after that you know it's
not as though every night one is to
spend the night in prayer but they are
those experiences and I've had that same
type of experience where maybe you're
facing a particular trial or maybe there
is a health issue in the family or maybe
there is a child that needs special
intercessory prayer and it's a burden on
your heart it's not that hard to pray
pretty pretty close to all night if if
your soul is heavy and you're earnestly
seeking God for intervention whether
it's praying for somebody who is sick or
whether it's praying for salvation of
somebody else those times that Jesus
prayed all night ones that we have
recorded we find that after that Jesus
would often do something special as
related to the disciples a one time he
prayed all night and then he called the
12 disciples and you know ordained them
for service so to pray all night usually
you need to have a good reason to
otherwise you end up just saying the
same thing over and over again and the
Bible says don't pray in vain repetition
but if your heart is burdened with
something you know it's it's not that
difficult to pray if
you Saints the need for God's praise and
some blessing yeah and don't feel bad
Teresa because when Jesus prayed that
night before the Garden of Gethsemane he
asked the disciples to pray with them
and they fell asleep so sometimes the
Spirit is willing but the flesh is weak
nothing wrong with taking a break if
you're committing a night to prayer you
might just you know start instead of
committing all night so yeah I want to
spend a whole hour in prayer
most people don't spend more than 10
minutes in prayer daily I'm talking
about formal prayer so yeah good
question though I've thought that before
spending a whole night in prayer how can
you work the next day well you know we
do have a book talking about prayer and
it's called teach us to pray and it
deals with these principles not only a
prayer but I think it's also referring
to the attitude things that we want to
pray about and we'll be happy to send
this to AU Teresa or anyone who would
like to learn more about how you can
have a vibrant prayer life the number to
call for that is eight hundred eight
three five six seven four seven and
again you can ask for the book teach us
to pray and it ties in to what the
disciples asked Jesus after Christ had
been praying the disciples came to him
and said teach us to pray and that's a
good thing for us to ask what pastor
like we're looking at the clock I don't
think we have enough time in tonight's
program to take another call it probably
won't be fair but for those of you are
still on hold we apologize we weren't
able to get to your question this
evening but we are God willing planning
to have another program live next Sunday
and we're nowhere to go shion's okay
anywhere we're gonna be here friends
Matt if a queen might just stick out in
this room for another week so we'll just
be praying for a whole week you know in
closing just want to back up we did have
two questions in 1st Timothy 4 we've got
a free lesson called God's free health
plan and go to the website and ask for
that as well
hey listening friends look forward to
talking together about the Word of God
again next week
thank you for listening to today's
broadcast
we hope you understand your Bible even
better than before Bible answers live is
produced by amazing facts International
a faith-based ministry located in
Granite Bay California if you enjoy
hearing solid biblical answers on Bible
answers live you can have those same
insights at your fingertips through the
amazing facts prophecy Study Bible
the updated hardcover version is
available at its lowest price ever and
includes the complete set of amazing
facts 27 study guides plus a Bible
numbers and symbols charts and eight
pages of colorful maps this best-ever
Bible gives you a biblical cyclope dick
index words of Christ in red chronology
of the Old Testament
along with Doug Bachelors how to study
the Bible feature and much more call us
at AF bookstore to learn more about it
at one eight hundred five thirty eight
seventy two seventy five the amazing
facts prophecy Study Bible stands apart
from other Bibles giving you the same
solid answers you hear each week on
Bible answers live order your copy today
at AF bookstore calm or by calling 1-800
five thirty eight seventy two seventy
five can't get enough amazing facts
Bible study you don't have to wait until
next week to enjoy more truth filled
programming visit the amazing facts
media library at aft vor G at aft vor G
you can enjoy video and audio
presentations as well as printed
material all free of charge 24 hours a
day seven days a week right from your
computer or mobile device visit aft vo
RG DT no amazing backs has a free Bible
school that you can do from the comfort
of your own home it includes 27
beautifully illustrated study lessons to
aid in your study of God's words sign up
today for this free Bible study course
by calling 184 four two one five seven
thousand that's one eight four four two
one five seven thousand
[Music]
for life-changing Christian resources
visit AF bookstore calm
[Music]
if you'd like to enhance your study of
God's Word
visit our website at WWE
and make sure to check out our online
bookstore at AF bookstore com which
offers thousands of inspiring books DVDs
and more to help you get the most out of
God's Word to take advantage of the
offers you've heard on this broadcast
call us at
[Music]
you